you look gorgeous in this fashion over
it's not it's a pooza
thank you what do you love most about
cardi B we're out here we're celebrating
her tonight
she's fearless and I feel like she's the
person that we all wish to be sometimes
and that's why she's as big as she is
she's an icon
I mean self-made surely and in the word
and I'm so happy that I get to be here
and that the world gets to be influenced
by her because she's real and she just
shares what's on her mind just like
everyone else does but in private do you
feel like as a celebrity it's harder to
do that like do you feel like you have a
filter on your life yeah depending on
what people expect from you for sure
absolutely people expect me to be a role
model and I'm sure with other people so
she's just that person it's just like I
can be a role model but I'm living my
life so that's what's cool
have you ever met her I haven't and I'm
really nervous my mother said she's
really nice so I'm excited she's
literally the nicest okay that's that's
so cool I really appreciate you Shawn we
love even after all I mean you still
family ask you quickly about empire and
there's a decision not to bring Jessie
back next season how are you feeling
about that I've been a supporter of his
throughout this whole situation just
because we're so close but we're so far
and in in saying that we work with him
every day we may go out with him but
when this happened we're just like every
other person watching TV so I just
support him and I hope that he has
future great endeavors how would the
cast after that happened like what were
you guys like we were confused just like
everyone else we didn't know what to
think we supported him at first and then
we didn't know what to think and I feel
like I feel like we handled it
beautifully everyone is supporting him
regardless of the facts so that's all we
can do we're friends right are you in
contact with him are you talking to him
No
[Music]